il fait chaud il fait soleil lundi après
midi héloïse paquet poisson fait du
macramé dans un parc de québec elle
décide de retirer son chandail c'est
alors que des policiers lui demandent de
se couvrir elle a dénoncé cette
situation sur facebook sa publication
partager des milliers de fois à récolter
des centaines de réactions c'était le
catalyst pour que ça explose sur
plusieurs études après avoir lu
l'histoire d'eloïse alice lacroix a
lancé un appel à sortir manifesté seins
nus pour celles qui le voudront les
moeurs doivent changer pense-t-elle on
sait tous que l'égalité des sexes n'est
pas encore arrivé que je pense entre
autres à ce qui s'est passé avec la dame
au centre eaton que ces fermes et or
pour allaiter avec les codes
vestimentaires dans les écoles qui sont
encore questionné mais l'idée de voir
une femme c'est nu en public continue de
susciter le malaise on voit les ça comme
quelque chose de super sexuelle il faut
cacher mais dans les années 60 il ya eu
exactement les mêmes mêmes débats avec
la mini jeux vous aimez porter le mini
jeu
[Musique]
ça semble anodin mais c'est que ça en
dit beaucoup sur la puissance du tabou
sur l'air la volonté très insidieuse de
contrôler le corps des femmes l'autre et
sylvie boisvert a déjà mené l'expérience
il ya huit ans elle a déambulé dans les
rues seins nus l'article est devenue
virale les réactions nombreuses si
j'avais été un homme qui aurait été
parfaitement anonyme parce que j'étais
une femme ça le tout changé pour moi à
ce moment là un signe du chemin qu'il
reste à parcourir selon elle car année
après année le débat est relancé la
manifestation qui s'organisent ces mêmes
éviter au parlement à québec c'est leur
droit puis alesi j'ai aucun problème
avec ça en théorie rien dans le code
criminel canadien interdit aux femmes
d'être seins nus en public seuls les
actes indécents sont interdits
d'ailleurs les tribunaux se sont déjà
penchés sur la question en ontario et en
colombie britannique
ils ont donné raison aux femmes ici qui
me permettrait au canada montréal